‏the hypocrit
[Silence]
الايوبي
‏ages
even though
leaders
انج
[Silence]
‏this
notomatic
not prop said
how it is and if would listen to them we
would we would not be having this
conversation
عمر بن عبد العزيز
ice
other timeن
حنبل
and
sched him there many who
detractors oh he should just say
whatever they asking for him to say he
shouldn't do this he shouldn't
‏I think I believe my opinion I think so
in
Allahs bestion
right
however this isه
تكون لكم ويريد الله ان يحق الحق بكلماته
ويقطع دابر الكافرين ليحق ق الحق ويبطل
الباطل ولو كره المجرمون نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يعلمنا ما
ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا وان يزيدنا
قوه وايمانا ويقينا وتوكلا عليه سبحانه
وتعالى وعلى الحق والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد